the trajectory estimation problem that
we considered gives you a first glimpse
into a large field that deals with
linear normal models in this segment I
will just give you a preview of what
happens in that field although we will
not attempt to prove or justify anything
what happens in this field is that we're
dealing with models where there are some
underlying independent normal random
variables and then the random variables
of interest the unknown parameters and
the observations can all be expressed as
linear functions of these independent
normals since linear functions of
independent normals are normal in
particular this means that the theta J
and the X I are all normal random
variables carrying out inference within
this class of models goes under the name
of linear regression one can proceed
using pretty much the same steps as we
had in the trajectory estimation problem
and write down formulas for the
posterior and it turns out that in every
case the posterior of the parameter
vector takes a form which is the
exponential of and the negative of a
quadratic function of the parameters and
this means in particular that in order
to find the map estimate of the vector
theta what we need to do is to just
minimize this quadratic function with
respect to theta and minimizing a
quadratic function is done by taking
derivatives and setting them to zero
which leads us to a system of linear
equations exactly as in the trajectory
inference problem and this means that
numerically it is very simple to come up
with a map estimate there is an
interesting fact that comes out of the
algebra involved namely that the map
estimate of each one of the parameters
turns out to also be a linear function
of the observations we saw this property
in the estimators that we derived
for simpler cases in this lecture
sequence it turns out that this property
is still true and this is an appealing
and desirable property because it means
that these estimators can be applied
very efficiently in practice without
having to do any complicated
calculations finally there's a number of
important facts some of which we have
seen in our examples which are true in
very big generality one fact is that the
maximum a-posteriori probability
estimate of some parameter turns out to
be the same as the conditional
expectation of that parameter
furthermore if you look at this joint
density of all the theta parameters and
from it you find the marginal density of
the theta parameters always within this
conditional universe it turns out that
this marginal posterior PDF is itself
normal since it is normal it's mean
which is this quantity it's going to be
equal to its peak and therefore it is
equal also to the map estimate that
would be derived from this marginal PDF
so what do we have here
there are two ways of coming up with map
estimates one way is to find the peak of
the joint PDF and then read out the
different components of theta another
way of coming up with map estimates is
to find for each parameter the marginal
PDF and look at the peak of this
marginal PDF it turns out that for this
model these two approaches are going to
give you the same answer whether you
work with a marginal or with a joint you
get the same map estimates and this is a
reassuring property to have finally as
in the examples that we have worked in
more detail it turns out that the mean
squared error
conditioned on a particular observation
is the same no matter what the value of
that observation was and furthermore
there are fairly simple and easily
computable formulas that one can apply
in order to find what this mean squared
error is so to summarize this class of
models that involve linear relations and
normal random variables have a rich set
of important and elegant properties this
is one of the reasons why these models
are used very much in practice and
they're probably the most widely used
class of statistical models